my strongest critique of the Republicans
today is that they do not recognize that
America when Americans are economically
insecure Americans are less free the
Republican Party Talks a great deal
about individual and personal freedom
they see it as their mission to promote
the freedom of Americans and they
believe that the best way for Americans
to be as free as possible is for
government to be as limited as small as
possible for government to do as little
as possible I think that's fundamentally
wrong I think that people are most free
when government provides certain public
goods that people cannot provide for
themselves which in fact then allow them
to take advantage of their god-given
talents so if we don't we don't people
don't have decent health care if we have
a broken health care system in which
many Americans have no health care at
all and other Americans are trapped in
dead-end jobs and afraid to leave those
jobs to go back to school or to take and
to start a business because they feel
losing their health care they are in
fact less free to actualize the kind of
lives that they want to live if we have
a government that ignores the threat of
global warming and the possibility it
the threaded it poses the United States
that infringes all in the long term on
the freedom of Americans and if we have
a government that does not take the that
puts hacks in critical positions of
public authority as the bush
administration did when it came to FEMA
that we that we find ourselves in a
situation in New Orleans in which
Americans are radically unfree the
people of New Orleans are literally
imprisoned in their city and imprisoned
in the Superdome because the government
is not providing them the public goods
which they can't provide for themselves
which in fact allow them to be safe and
be free i think that the republicans
party biggest problem is they don't
recognize that the deterioration of the
american welfare state in a globalized
age has actually meant that America not
just that Americans are more
economically insecure but that Americans
have become less free to act to make of
themselves what they will that that
freedom paradoxically requires some
degree of security
that people who are who are who don't
feel economically secure are people who
in fact are less free to take risk if
you believe in risk-taking as
Republicans claim they do that you have
to start to rebuild the American welfare
state so Americans have some greater
degree of economic security